[Music]
so many fans are jonesing for
sister-sister easily update what can you
tell us you know I will say this we are
definitely closer than ever
like that's basically all I can say but
I'm getting excited and I will say that
I feel like the fans are even making me
even more excited they're like rooting
me on I'm like oh hey you wow you guys
want this okay we're gonna make it
happen you know so we're getting close
yeah the rest of the cast be involved if
they could come back um yes as I as I
know of now you know definitely jackée
Harry and Tim Reid will definitely be a
part of the show given any thoughts of
where the story would pick up I think I
would want it to kind of pick up with
where our lives are now we're married
with kids but I I think I would
definitely want it to focus on the power
of a sisterhood you know how wonderful
and amazing that sisterhood in that
relationship can be and family home
because family is so important to me and
now tia is sharing life hacks with
families on her new youtube series Tia
Baris quick fix we all have those little
dilemmas in life that could use a fast
and quick solution what inspired this
this show on your channel yeah I mean
I'm a mom and I'm a workaholic I love my
job
I love what I do but what comes with
that is I'm extremely busy so I'm always
looking for you know life hacks or just
hacks and in general to make my life
easier whether that's you know sheet pan
dinners doesn't this look delicious or
just finding some sort of shortcuts just
to make our lives you know fun and
entertaining and just just easier no it
down
yes nitwit deal
you